[Música]
sus palabras siguen resonando 40 años
después cuando afirmo a los legisladores
franceses que no hay hombres en la
tierra en quienes se deba perder
totalmente la esperanza en septiembre de
1981 joven bad under pidió formalmente
al fin de la pena de muerte alegando que
la justicia es humana y por lo tanto
falible
tengo el honor en nombre del gobierno de
la república francesa de someter a la
asamblea nacional la abolición de la
pena capital en francia la abolición de
la pena
cuando josué metieron llegó a la
presidencia la pena de muerte seguía en
vigor incluso en su forma más
escalofriante la guillotina en aquel
momento francia era el último país de
europa con la excepción de belarús que
mantenía la pena capital y la opinión
pública estaba poco dispuesta a abolirla
pero paraba dantec y un frasco a meter
aún no he elegido la república debía
construirse sobre valores no sobre
encuestas
no estoy en contra de la pena de muerte
y no necesito leer los sondeos de
opinión que dicen lo contrario una vez
elegido presidente emitió nombró abad
ante el ministro de justicia la
abolición de la pena de muerte se
convirtió en una prioridad para el nuevo
gobierno socialista pero se encontró con
una fuerte resistencia de algunos
sectores
cuando se suprima totalmente es cuando
los asesinos van a estar realmente
encantados no habrá límite
la abolición de la pena de muerte fue
finalmente promulgada el 9 de octubre de
1981 cuatro décadas después y a sus 93
años esa batalla no ha terminado para
balancear sigue luchando por la
abolición universal de la pena de muerte
que aún se aplica en 55 países